JONATHAN BERI: This session
we're going to talk about the
Hangouts API and how far the
Hangouts platform has come
over the year.
Allow me to introduce myself.
My name is Jonathan
Beri, and I'm a
developer advocate on Google+.
If you have questions about
Hangouts, Hangout apps, or any
other of the Google+ platform
features, please add me to
your circles.
That's the best way to ask
me questions and start a
conversation.
Today's agenda, we're going to
talk about several things,
starting with what is
the Hangouts API.
For those of you who've never
seen the Hangouts API, I'll
give you an overview of the
features, why should you as
developers build Hangout apps on
top of the API; go through
a bit of history to show where
we've come and where we're
going; talk about the API
itself, how you can use it;
and then finish off with
the future, where
we're going as a platform.
Just a quick poll, how
many people have
never been in a Hangout?
All right, so we have some
people who are making jokes in
the front, Alan.
How many people have used
a Hangout App before?
The mustache, most of you.
Great.
So what's the Hangouts API?
Well, this is the effects app
that we ship with Google+, and
it's a Hangout app.
And fundamentally a Hangout app
is an application that you
as a developer can build that is
integrated into the Hangout
experience.
It's something you
can control.
It's something that you can
create new experiences around.
And we as Google integrate that
for users, and they can
quickly and easily add that
to their conversation.
The pieces are very simple.
There's two major parts.
It's JavaScript and HTML.
It's regular code that we build
for the web, that you
can either have Google host
or you can host yourself.
And it's the APIs that we extend
on top of the Hangout
app to allow you to more deeply
integrate with the
overall video experience.
At the lowest level, a Hangout
app is just an iFramed app
that we shove into a Hangout.
So this is a mantra we like to
use around the platform team,
anything you can do
it in an iFrame
you can do in a Hangout.
So that opens up the
possibilities of the types of
applications you can build.
Because it's an iFrame
you can also host
it on your own servers.
So you can use whatever back-end
services you want,
whether it be Node or Python,
App Engine, Go.
You can use any database
you'd like, MySQL,
NoSQL, your SQL, whatever.
You can use the existing
technologies that you're
comfortable with to build
Hangout applications.
So why would you want to
build Hangout apps?
If you're building apps today
for the web, you can bring
those applications into a
multi-user video experience
that's real-time with
high engagement.
So if you have a standard
application that's really
useful, let's say in a
collaborative sense, that it's
valuable to have a shared
activity, bringing that to
Hangout lets you build on top of
that platform and add video
and real-timeness for free.
And it's built on top of
Google+, so you have that
social network that can connect
users in a seamless,
integrated way.
There's also another type of app
that's really exciting for
you as developers, and that is
to enhance the conversation.
Typically video chat platforms
may allow you to customize
some things, but with Hangout
apps you can actually tailor
the experience for the
type of conversations
users want to have.
Here's a screenshot of an
application called Hangout
Toolbox that allows you to see
who's talking and control
volumes of all the speakers
and configure how the
conversation can flow.
And you can use this for
broadcast scenarios or just
one-on-one with your
colleagues.
Let's talk a little bit about
history, especially for those
who may not have built
Hangout apps before.
Here's a timeline of the
Hangout apps journey.
It all started in late 2011
when Google+ launched.
We didn't have apps, but Google+
Hangouts shipped with
a built-in application, the
YouTube application, that
allowed users to watch a video
together as if you're on the
couch, even if you're millions
of miles away.
You're not millions--
maybe thousands.
But it sparked something
at Google.
This is the type of experiences
that we want
developers to build.
So we started working on
the Hangouts platform.
And we launched and developed
our preview in early 2012.
And from here on out we started
adding new features to
unlock new types of
applications.
The first applications that we
built was the Effects app.
And it was neat.
It's fun.
It allows you to integrate
little animations, overlays,
within the video stream.
It's very simple, fits on the
side of the screen, but it
sparked conversation.
Wearing a mustache or a snorkel,
as silly as it
sounds, can just start a whole
new thread of ideas.
And people at work are
using this to maybe
offload a little bit.
And we saw these types of
applications being built from
the early days.
A few months later we went
to general availability.
That means developers could
actually ship their
applications to all
Google+ users.
One of the first launched
apps was Scoot & Doodle.
It was built fully on the
application platform, and it
allowed people to
draw together.
You think about how simple
that is to do
in your daily lives.
You're at your table with your
niece or your daughter and you
want to draw together.
That's great, but what
if you're traveling?
Scoot & Doodle allowed you to
connect, even if you're in a
hotel room in Tokyo while your
kid's about to go sleep, and
draw something together.
And this app uses different
features of the platform, like
those overlays we saw that
were a mustache.
They used this part to show
the crayon you're using.
They also use the real-time APIs
that we built into the
platform to have the smooth
drawing experience seamlessly
with that fun video piece.
Then last year, I/O, I was on
a stage talking about how
Hangout apps have evolved,
and it was amazing.
We had even more apps built on
the platform, more engaging
types of conversations being
spunoff off these apps.
Here's another example that we
unlocked with another release.
This is called "Donut Horns."
It was built by one of our
friends at an agency.
And at I/O we announced a facial
movement recognition
API, similar to the overlay,
that just sticks to your face
with a simple API.
This allowed you to build
interactive demos like this,
where you could become a unicorn
and catch falling
doughnuts, clearly something you
want to do at I/O. That's
silly and fun, but this opens
up a whole new class of
applications, whether it be a
game like this or things for
accessibility and helping you
communicate and control
real-time interactive media.
And as we move forward we
released more and more APIs,
and the platform matured
and grew further.
For example, we launched a app
called Cameraman to enhance
the broadcast controls to enable
Hangouts on the air to
have a controllable experience
for those producers.
And then we exposed the API to
allow you to control who is in
or not in the Hangout.
We also had regular releases
improving the user experience
of Hangouts themselves to bring
Hangout apps to the
forefront of the conversation.
And we're still shipping today,
still improving on the
platform and making progress,
adding new features, and
unlocking new potential
in the applications.
So let's talk a little bit about
the actual API, a code
you can write, a way
you can integrate.
The API is built on five
very simple principles.
And these are methods that you
can invoke, events that you
can listen to and respond to, to
make your apps interactive
and seamlessly integrate with
the video experience.
These are just quick names,
but around people, the
real-time APIs, the video
effects themselves, and more
information about the Hangouts
to tailor the UI.
Let's walk through
a few examples.
Because this is a social
experience, a conversation,
the most important API is the
one that's around people.
So I have a series of
participant APIs that allow
you to know who's in the
Hangout, who's just joined the
Hangout, who's leaving the
Hangout, so you can make your
applications respond to those
events and integrate their
social identity to make it
a personal experience.
Here's a screenshot of
Hangout Toolbox.
When somebody joins the Hangout
you can see who they
are and control their
speaking volume.
If somebody has a booming voice
you can turn it down.
And if somebody's too soft
you can bump it up.
Another core class of APIs
is the real-timeness.
Hangouts themselves are
real-time and spontaneous.
If Richard is in a Hangout
and I see him, I'll want
to join with him.
It happens naturally.
So you have APIs around this
real-timeness of the Hangouts
themselves that you can
integrate into your
application.
And we provide APIs as well that
allow you to add another
level of real-time
responsiveness.
Again with Scoot & Doodle, they
use a series of APIs that
we collectively call the
real-time APIs to draw the
points that the user
is drawing and then
smoothly show the path.
This is used for games,
like a "Donut Horn,"
or a foosball game.
And just like the Hangouts, you
can make your applications
responsive in real time.
And the last class of APIs is
around the video, manipulating
the stream, adding the overlays
for fun and for
actual effectiveness.
Again, this is a combination of
a bunch of APIs, but they
overlay using the face-tracking
API.
The unicorn horn--
the unicorn game doesn't
actually have to write the
code to figure out where your
face is and stick it on.
They just attach image to what
we call a face, and the
Hangout tracks it for you.
They have balloons in the
background that move up and
down, simulating a floating
balloon, using another API.
And then, of course, the facial
recognition API-- the
application can know where the
face is on the page and then
make the animation
respond to it.
These are just a few ways
to use the same APIs.
Now a little bit about
the future.
Richard Dunn here is to talk
more about where we're going.
RICHARD DUNN: Hey guys,
I'm Richard Dunn.
I'm the lead engineer for
the Hangouts API.
And Johnson just filled you in a
little bit of the history of
how the API got started
and the basics.
And I get to do the fun
stuff, the demos.
And those of you that have
been with us from the
beginning will appreciate a lot
of the stuff that we've
done here, just trying to work
out the kinks, make everything
work a little better.
Where is the platform headed?
What do we want to
do in the future?
And how do we want to make the
experience easier for you to
develop against and really try
to get a lot of good Hangout
applications going?
Jonathan talked a lot about the
progress we've made over
the last year and a half.
I feel like we've released
a lot of rich APIs.
We've tried to cover all the new
features in Hangouts with
APIs so that you guys can build
the types of experiences
that we either haven't thought
of yet or haven't had the time
to work out.
I think the volume control is a
really good example of that.
You guys wanted to be able
to adjust that, and
you guys wrote it.
So what do we want
to do from here?
The first thing we want to do is
really focus on faster and
more flexible releases.
If you've followed along, we've
made regular updates to
the platform.
But I think that in a lot of
cases that was driven by us,
and we want to fix it so that
it's driven by you more and
that we get stuff out as
soon as it's ready.
So we're always sitting there
coding new APIs, and we want
to make sure that
they're in your
hands as fast as possible.
And as I said, we really want
to get your feedback.
So we want to be building APIs
based on the kind of things
you guys want to build
applications on.
We want to hear from you about
what the APIs should look
like, to just make it easier
for you to write your
applications.
And we want you to test stuff
out that we want to try out
and let us know how it works.
And of course, we're Google.
We always want to release
cool stuff.
So we're going to
keep doing that.
Let's talk about the first thing
we're going to do that
enables us to release
things faster.
So for those of you that have
been following along, we've
had a series of versions.
And as of today we're actually
going to switch to a new model
for releasing API.
Anyone that's familiar with
Chrome knows that Chrome uses
sort of a channel model where
you can follow a stable and a
beta channel and that
kind of thing.
And within those channels
things are just pushed
automatically.
So we're going to do that.
No more versions.
Instead of batching up APIs
and releasing them in a
particular version, we're just
going to have one channel, and
it'll go ahead and update
automatically with all the new
stuff we come out with.
So this is going to be
the stable channel.
We're going to have
a stable channel.
If you've written an app before,
you know it's just
basically a single JavaScript
include.
We've changed it a little bit.
You'll notice there's no real
version number in here.
So when we release new stuff,
it'll just automatically come
into this channel.
The stable API is what you're
going to be using in all of
your public applications.
It's going to have the APIs
that we've very thoroughly
tested and run by and
made sure that
everyone is happy with.
So this is the stuff that
we're very confident.
So far we've essentially made
all stable releases, so just
imagine that continuing but
on a faster schedule.
The fun new stuff, though, is
we're actually introducing a
second channel, which is
a developer channel.
And this is where we're going to
have basically use this as
a playground for new features.
This is where we're going to
put stuff that we have
developed internally but
maybe isn't quite
ready for prime time.
This is where we'll release new
APIs initially so that you
guys can give us feedback on do
they look right, do they do
all the things that you
want to do, is it too
complicated, et cetera.
This will be for non-public
applications.
So if anyone's familiar with
developing, you can set your
app to be public.
This for your private
applications.
This is for you to
play around with.
As I said, everything's not
ready for prime time.
It's going to be a little bit of
the Wild West in there, but
I think you guys will
have fun with it.
But on that note, we want you
to actually be using these
private applications and testing
them out and trying to
use them in real world.
So also today we're going to
announce a new developer
experience.
Anyone that's developed a
Hangout app knows that we have
this isolated sandbox that
you run in right now.
That's where you run your
developed apps.
It's a little bit wonky.
You can't invite people,
it's not related to
post, things like that.
A lot of Hangout app developers
are also very
active in Hangouts.
So there's this disconnect
between the apps they're
developing and the Hangouts
they're in.
So we're going to introduce
a new developer experience
that's going to let you
run your private
apps in regular Hangouts.
And I'm just going to go ahead
and demo that, so bear with me
a little bit here.
If I go into a Hangout--
and everyone's familiar with
the basic UX here.
I've got some apps on
the left, et cetera.
And if I go into our app
picker, you'll see the
featured and recent tabs.
And what we've added is
this developer tab.
Anyone that's been in the
sandbox has seen this.
And if I go into that, this'll
actually list the apps that
I'm currently developing.
So I just put in one of our
sample apps as a test here.
And you can see that I can load
it, and I have, at the
top, the familiar
developer bar.
This lets me do stuff
like reload the
app, reset the state.
This is great if you're just
sitting there hacking the
JavaScript.
Really lets you figure it out.
I'm just going to go ahead and
start another application real
quick, for the sake
of the demo.
OK, so I'm just in a Hangout.
I've got a regular public
app, doesn't have
any developer tools.
I have an app that I'm working
on, has the developer tools.
And let's go ahead and
get somebody in this
Hangout with me.
I'm just going to Hangout
with myself, because
that's always fun.
And when my other half comes
in, we can see that I'm
running the public app, the
effects app, but I don't see
my developed app.
So the developed apps are run
privately within the Hangout.
So this is great if you're
just wanting
to test it out yourself.
It's not really ready, but you
just want to play around with
the app in a real-world
environment.
You get real people in there.
But of course, that's no fun.
You want to test it with
real people as well.
So what we've added is another
button to the developer
toolbar, which allows you
to share the app.
And what this is going to do
is basically give everyone
else in the Hangout with you a
one-time pass to play around
with this app.
So as long as they're still in
the Hangout with you, they can
see the app, they can
interact with it.
They move on to another Hangout,
they don't have it.
So basically this is great
for beta testing.
You can get your developers
in there.
If anyone's done this before,
you have this weird thing
where you had to add
people to the teams
and things like that.
We're just making it easier.
So let me just demonstrate.
You can see on the left, I can
still see only that I'm in the
public effects app.
But if I as the developer hit
Share App here, now everyone
else in the Hangout
can see it.
And they go in, and they can
run the app as normal.
We are going to put up a little
warning, just to make
sure that the other side knows
that this is a developed app,
it's maybe not ready for
prime time, et cetera.
But as soon as they click
through they can run it.
Come on.
All right, well, let's not
worry too much about it.
But let's assume that's
going to load.
There we go.
The demo gods are not
smiling on me.
You get the general
idea, though.
They'll be able to see the app
just like everyone else.
Let's go back to there.
That's our new developer
experience.
Just to sum up, no
more sandbox.
We're actually going to end
up retiring the sandbox.
We'll give you a little time
to get used to the new
experience, but basically just
going to retire it and move to
this model.
And you'll just, as you're
developing apps, develop them
in regular Hangouts.
Obviously you can just be in a
Hangout with yourself and play
around with it in there, but
if you want to bring other
people into it, see how it works
in the real world, or
even share it with them, you
can run it privately or you
can share with others
in your Hangout.
So that's our new developer
experience.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD DUNN: I can see some
of the veterans in the room
are happy with that.
So we have this new
channel model.
We're giving you new stuff.
And I wouldn't want to give you
new stuff without actually
giving you new stuff, so we
also have some new APIs to
announce today in both the
stable channel and the
developer channel.
So let's start with the
stable channel.
Jonathan pointed out that one
class of apps that really
helps is these enhancement apps,
the things the tend to
run in the sidebar that set the
experience of the Hangout
the way you want it.
Things like effects, things like
volume control, things
like, anyone that's watched an
HOA, the very popular Lower
Thirds application that lets me
show a title, these are the
kinds of things that a lot of
people there are in a lot of
Hangouts are just bringing
up every time
they go into a Hangout.
So why should you actually
have to click on
that app to run it?
Why don't we just
load it for you?
We're introducing a new API
today to let the app autoload
itself whenever you
go into a Hangout.
So let's demo that.
I'm going to get out
of this Hangout.
This is the Hangout Toolbox.
Anyone that's familiar with
this, it's basically a bunch
of utility things.
And one of the more--
I'm going to go ahead
and close this--
popular ones is the
Lower Third.
So here, if you've watched the
news, I can set a lower third
that gives my name, what
I do, et cetera.
This is great if you're just
coming into a Hangout, maybe
you're with strangers, you want
to give them a little bit
of an update as to
who you are.
And as I said, it's great on
an HOA where you don't
necessarily have the context
of seeing who's in there.
We've added a new option that
lets an application set itself
to be auto-loaded.
So they've updated their app
here to enable that.
And I can actually
click this on.
And when I click this on, I'll
get a little warning that lets
me know that this is going to
auto-load the next time I
want, I can undo it, all
that kind of thing.
But if I did really want this
and I go into another Hangout,
it has already started.
And in fact, you can see
that my Lower Third
popped up as well.
I'm going to give a little shout
out to the Drive team,
who has a new API for
application data.
And I think this is a great
way to basically let an
application store, say,
a config file.
And what they've done with
Toolbox is say, we'll store
your Lower Thirds.
And when you auto-start, we'll
actually auto-turn-on your
Lower Thirds.
So anyone that's done a
lot of HOAs is going
to love this feature.
We really encourage anyone
that's doing an enhancement
app that they think would be
useful to run in every Hangout
to turn this on.
And we'd love to see a lot more
of these kind of tools
that let you shape the
experience of a Hangout.
To sum up, you can now set
your app to auto-load.
The user will confirm that
this is what they want.
You might want to look into
some of the Drive stuff.
And I encourage you go to some
of the Drive talks to see how
you might make that experience
as seamless as possible.
You could even imagine hiding
the app when it comes up and
knows exactly what
it wants to do.
And this is really allowing you
to set your Hangout the
way you want it.
So that's going to be in
the stable channel.
So that'll actually be available
for public apps
immediately.
In the developer channel
we basically have
a set of new effects.
And I think that these effects
are fairly exciting.
But they still need some
tweaking, so that's why we're
putting them in the developer
channel and we're letting you
take a look at them, use them
out, and give us feedback on
how they're working.
Let me demonstrate
two of those.
I'll leave this Hangout.
The first one, for those of you
that are familiar with our
facial tracking, should come
as an expected evolution of
that, and that is
hand tracking.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, actually, I know exactly
what's happening there.
Does anyone want to sit here
and wait while I fix it?
I think we can fix it.
Why don't I skip to the
other one while
I'm fixing it, though?
Actually, I'll just
talk through it.
Hand tracking, I think it's
fairly straightforward.
We've had facial tracking
for quite a while.
So you've had the ability to
see the face, see points on
the face, track them along,
put the overlays on top.
Jonathan mentioned
the Effects app.
We've had the snorkel mask
and let that do it.
But you can also actually
track the face.
So if you want to write your
own game logic or whatever
that deals with that, you can.
And so we've added
this for hands.
So now if I hold my hand up, we
can actually identify the
center of the hand and track the
hand as you're doing it.
So you could imagine writing
applications where somebody
raises their hand to answer a
question and the app actually
automatically picks up that
they've raised their
hand, and does that.
Or we had an application
released that was ping pong
with your face.
And as fun as it is to play ping
pong with your face, I
think you probably would rather
play it with your hand.
So let's do that.
OK, So that's one
of the effects.
And the other one, I know that
the tech guys here were very
excited about, and that's
background replacement.
We're still playing around with
this, but if anyone's
familiar with this, I'm sick
of being at I/O and I would
rather be on a beach.
So I can just go ahead
and select something,
and I'm on a beach.
Obviously you can see it's a
little raw with picking up.
We've actually got this slider
in the app here that plays
around with how much of the
background it picks up.
This is why we want to put it
in the developer channel.
We want to have you
guys try it out.
There's a lot of knobs to tweak,
and we'd like you guys
to build apps around it, get
people to play with those, see
what things work, what
things don't.
We'll have general background
replacement where I can just
replace the background behind
me with any image, and then
kind of a cool feature that's
background blur, where it
really just blurs out the
back very subtly and
focuses on your face.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD DUNN: I can.
Let me go back.
Yeah, I should've done that.
I apologize.
Let's do that.
There you go.
It's a little better.
We noticed this yesterday.
For some reason, under the
lights my forehead tends to
wash out pretty well.
But you see I can actually
adjust down how much it thinks
is background and
how much isn't.
And you can get pretty good.
Obviously this works better in
certain situations, like
against a solid background,
that kind of thing.
But again, we really want you
guys to play around with this,
let us know under what
conditions it works good, and
what you think you
can do with it.
Those are the effects, hand
tracking, background
replacement, and background
blur.
Please try them out, please play
around with them, and let
us know what works,
what doesn't.
And this is where we're really
going to try and use the
developer channel.
We want to hear the
feedback from you.
And we want to change the API to
look the right way, adjust
the parameters so that it
works well for everyone.
And on that topic, how are
we going to get this
feedback from you?
Since the last I/O we've
released communities and that
kind of thing.
And we really want to focus on
creating a good community
around Hangout app
development.
So anyone that's familiar with
the Google+ Developers
community, you know
that there's a
Hangouts category in there.
It's a little sparse
in terms of posts.
We want to change that.
We're really going to try
to engage with that.
I think you should watch
in the next few weeks.
We'll deep-dive into some
of the stuff that
I've announced today.
This is where we'll start
posting all the
updates to the APIs.
So you'd follow that community
to see all the new APIs in the
dev channel, see when they get
upgraded to the stable
channel, that kind of thing.
So I encourage you
all to join.
We're going to get the engineers
from the team
involved as well and really just
both take your feedback,
solicit your ideas for what you
want to build, and what
APIs we can unlock for you.
So as I said, we'll post
the API updates.
And we want your feedback.
Just a little upsell, we
have a code lab on
Friday at 2:00 PM.
We'll be going through some of
these things, building a
simple app to that covers
all the APIs that
Jonathan talked about.
I think it's got some of the
new stuff in it-- hand
tracking, at least.
So if you're interested in that,
I encourage you all to
show up and see how easy it
is to build Hangout apps.
Let me bring Jonathan back up,
and I think we'll just take
any questions you have.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN BERI: There are
mics over here if
you've got some questions.
RICHARD DUNN: Alan has
a question, I'm sure.
JONATHAN BERI: Please go up to
the mic so people in the
recording of the stream
can hear it.
AUDIENCE: Does the hand tracking
track both hands,
like left and right
at the same time?
Do you know which hand
is being held up?
RICHARD DUNN: I think it's
right now just one.
And it does the same
thing that you
do with face tracking.
So it's just the main--
oh, OK, no, Patrick
tells me it's two.
So you will get both hands.
Does it identify left
versus right?
I forget.
Yeah.
So you'll actually be able to
figure out left and right
hands as well.
AUDIENCE: How far do you think
we are from getting HD video
inside Hangouts?
RICHARD DUNN: That's
a good question.
Chi, you want to
field that one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN BERI: For those
watching the recording, we
don't talk about upcoming
features.
But that would be awesome.
RICHARD DUNN: That
would be awesome.
JONATHAN BERI: I would
love that.
AUDIENCE: The auto-start feature
for an app, that's
only triggered by a user
volunteering for the app?
It's not triggered by a Hangout
owner saying, this app
is required for this Hangout?
RICHARD DUNN: Correct.
Right now it's centered around
the app, basically providing
the UX for the user to
say, hey, I want to
auto-run this app.
AUDIENCE: So it means in every
Hangout that I'm joining I
want this app to run, not in
every Hangout that I own.
RICHARD DUNN: Correct.
So think about the experience
that you want
to have in a Hangout.
This lets you craft that
experience using apps.
We never really officially
announced this, but one thing
we did a few weeks ago was
remove the restriction of only
running two apps at a time.
Part of it was to enable this,
so you can actually run as
many of these extensions
as you want.
If you've got an extension that
sets your lower third,
that runs as one thing.
If you've got something else
that, I don't know, does skin
softening or something like that
on your avatar, you can
run that as a second
extension.
JONATHAN BERI: Good
question, though.
AUDIENCE: One of the questions
I have, especially with
backgrounds, all the rest,
is brand marketing.
One of the very cool things to
do if you're a game company
would be have a Hangout for your
specific game and have
the background graphic be your
specific game and allow people
to do defaults and
stuff like that.
Perfect would be when they come
into the Hangout, certain
apps are pre-automatically
installed or required.
So the other way would be very
good for brand marketing.
They join a game, say the
Godfather or something.
They join that game, and they
would automatically have the
same experience of everyone
else who's in that
Hangout at that time.
It's a much more branded
way of doing it.
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah, we've
definitely heard
that feedback before.
And I think if you saw our
recent integration with
YouTube's Coachella streaming,
we did something similar to
that where when they came in
they automatically had both
the YouTube app that was
streaming this and the
Coachella stuff.
So we're definitely working
on that area, and
we'll let you know.
JONATHAN BERI: Actually, a lot
of agencies that I work with
use a feature we call
the Hangout Button.
It's actually a link that
allows you to put on a
webpage, a Facebook post,
wherever, that does one of two
things for both.
You can specify an app to load
if the user clicks on that
Hangout button.
So it'll load your
branded app.
And you can also pass in
metadata with that link.
Let's say it's a sports
team site and they
have a Hangout button.
They can pass what page they're
on, some campaign
tracking, as well as pre-load
that particular team's app.
So you can do a lot of
that stuff today.
AUDIENCE: I realize you just
announced hand tracking, but
is finger tracking
on the roadmap?
RICHARD DUNN: I don't know how
detailed we're going to get.
AUDIENCE: Just a supplemental
question, is the image
buffered data ever going to be
exposed so we can do our own
custom effects [INAUDIBLE]
segmentation?
RICHARD DUNN: I think the big
issue there is really a
privacy thing and just giving
third parties access to that.
I'm sure if we could find a safe
way to do it, we would
consider it.
But we really have no
plans for that now,
just for that reason.
JONATHAN BERI: Though we'd love
to hear what you would do
with that data.
RICHARD DUNN: We could enable
very specific scenarios.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, because if
it's something really cool
and interesting, maybe we can
solve that problem with
another API that doesn't expose
the private graphing
information but enables you
to do something really
interesting.
We'd love to hear
that feedback.
AUDIENCE: I'm Jeff Douglas with
"Stack Overflow." And I
want to first say kudos
for the Hangout.
It's changed the dynamic
of our team.
JONATHAN BERI: Oh, fantastic.
RICHARD DUNN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And we've actually
integrated our own internal
chat system as a Hangout
application.
RICHARD DUNN: Awesome.
That's what it's there for.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
One thing I had a question is
one feature that's been
deployed recently, in the last
couple weeks, is muting while
you're typing.
There are features like that
that sometimes come into
Hangout's experience that
we wish we could
somehow turn off.
Is there a way or is there a
plan for some [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD DUNN: I think if you
follow some of the releases
we've done, in general we've
tried to follow all the new
features pretty quickly
with an API.
And I think moving to the
channel system is really going
to let us iterate even
faster on that.
And so as soon as a feature
comes out, we should pretty
quickly release an
API for that.
I hadn't heard that particular
one, but we'll definitely keep
that in mind as a
feature request.
AUDIENCE: As you know, we're all
coders, so as we're typing
and [INAUDIBLE] mute
it, it's--
RICHARD DUNN: Understandable.
JONATHAN BERI: This was good
feedback for the algorithm we
use to do that.
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah.
Figure out if the person's a
programmer by what they're
wearing, and then don't--
JONATHAN BERI: What
hour they are on.
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah, if it's
3:00 in the morning--
JONATHAN BERI: What port's
open on the machine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Studio.
First, thank you for letting the
hosts hide the film script
and for letting the host mute
notifications as needed.
RICHARD DUNN: Yes, other new
APIs released today.
AUDIENCE: Is there a technical
or business reason why a post
wouldn't be able to say, I want
everybody who enters this
Hangout to load this specific
application?
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD DUNN: I think this is
really a good example of a use
case that's emerged since
Hangout started, and really
because of HOA, probably.
This is stuff we weren't
think about on day one.
Remember, we didn't have
Hangouts on air.
So we've definitely heard
that feedback.
And as I said, we're
exploring that.
JONATHAN BERI: One nuance is
users do provide permission to
expose their Google data, or if
the particular app is using
another Google API.
So some apps may not be
able to auto-authorize
those kind of things.
AUDIENCE: Could be that's an
opportunity for them to
decline and just not come
into a Hangout.
JONATHAN BERI: That's
a good idea.
We're actually out of time.
Is there a quick question?
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
JONATHAN BERI: This will be
the last quick question.
AUDIENCE: We can screen
share video and stuff.
Is there any way we
can audio share?
Because if I want to share a
video, I can share the video
part of it, but I can't
also share the
audio at the same time.
Or if I want to play a song and
I want people to hear it,
or even some way to be able to
share a YouTube video with the
other people.
I know we can watch a YouTube
video together, but if I'm
doing a Hangout on air, there's
no way for me to share
that YouTube video without
a lot of wires.
RICHARD DUNN: I've actually
not heard that particular
request before, so that's
interesting.
But just sort of off the top
of my head, there are
definitely complications with
audio that aren't there with
video, just because am I
playing it locally--
if you've ever played with the
YouTube app, you have that
push-to-talk system, just
because you don't want the
YouTube video conflicting, being
fed back through, and
that kind of thing.
So definitely something
to look into.
As I said, it's the first time
I've heard that request, but
I'd love to look into it.
AUDIENCE: We're doing a show and
we're going to present a
Russian meteorite exploding,
and there's video and audio
going along with it.
We want to share it with people,
we can bring up the
YouTube or bring up even just
a video and show it, but the
audio won't get piped through,
so we have to come up with
some other way [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN BERI: I have seen
some pretty sophisticated
solutions to some of these
problems by using virtual
harbor drivers, especially
in interesting embedded
applications or robotics
or things like that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I could
just pipe the input.
There's ways to do it, but
people always want to share
video and they can't
get the audio.
JONATHAN BERI: [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks, guys.
RICHARD DUNN: We'd better
clear the room.
We'll be around for a
little bit, if you
have further questions.
JONATHAN BERI: Perfect.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]